in the old days people would say sex
sells you want to sell a product
you put some hot chickie wearing not so
much clothing and then that's how you're
going to sell a product
these days i guess sex still sells in
the sense that sexual grievance
sells even more than that race hustling
oh that sells like crazy that's all
you're getting in commercials
i have been doing better in these
commercials that you sent in i've been
trying to guess what
product the company is actually selling
beyond sjw nonsense
and i've been getting better my my
average was not so great early on
and now it's a little bit higher i'm
going to try to push myself over that
50 threshold i want to get into the next
stage before we get to this video though
this is sponsored by blinkist blinkist
brings you knowledge from top
non-fiction and podcasts
so you can learn anytime anywhere more
from them later first
let us begin with the first woke
commercial
spikely not off to a good start place
our people our block is just like yours
full of the people who shaped you they
all deserve
care and access take coffee no matter
their dress
income or skin color is it coffee to get
the vaccine it's the only
actual product i've seen in here oh
there's uber yeah okay
i want you want to help donate a ride
today
oh okay that's man that's a tricky one
because i saw the uber logo kind of a
little bit in the corner
before he said it so i don't i don't
know if i get credit for that
this one to me though it actually does
make a little bit more sense because the
the whole liberal establishment scheme
to make you all get the new vaccine is
to say that you're not going to be able
to use any
any services unless you get the vaccine
right so say there's no government
mandate you just can't leave your house
if you don't have the vaccine and so
uber is a classic example right
oh yeah no you don't need the vaccine
you just can't go anywhere you have to
stay at home so i
this one actually does make a little bit
more sense to me
let's go to the next one
the american dream
it wasn't made for everybody oh gosh
they forgot about one very important
detail
black america oh yeah they totally
forgot yeah
right yeah that's why they fought a
bloody civil war right
and while black success isn't always a
story of accomplishment
but a story of getting up
but black americans woke up a long time
ago and set out to make their own dream
they had to we've seen it in atlanta
entrepreneurship or something and
communities all around america
it's like business lending or something
black voices
matter i'm gonna say it's like a bank or
something like that
america's dream is the real american
dream because it means
a chance to succeed
sprite is supporting blm so that
you know this would have look there's
obviously a bunch of nonsense the
founders they
totally forgot about black people that's
why they had very serious debates even
at the constitutional convention
about the question of slavery about
representation about
yeah that's why they fought a bloody
civil war in the 1860s because they just
totally forgot about black people right
yeah not quite
but whatever that's kind of boilerplate
leftist nonsense if this had been for
but black people they're pulling
themselves up they're starting
businesses you think okay good this is
for a bank this is for
some entrepreneurial organization no
it's for a sugary soda
yes nothing says empowerment like
diabetes
like giving yourself even you know by
the way a lot of these commercials that
you're seeing now they're about how
black people are disproportionately
affected by the coronavirus
and one explanation for this might be
that rates of obesity and
bad bad health situations are
disproportionately
present in the black community and covid
disproportionately affects people with
those kinds of health issues
so how are you going to fix it drink a
ton of highly caloric
sugary soft drinks does it happen to you
that you want to read a book but you
know you just don't have the time we're
all so busy well instead of having to
find the time to read a whole book you
can listen to all the highlights
in just 15 minutes how it seems crazy
that's
the only way you could do that is is
probably by reading my first book my
blank book then you can read that 15 16
minutes
most books how do you do it well
blinkist allows you to save time
money and learn new things faster than
ever
blinkist brings you knowledge from top
non-fiction and podcasts
so you can learn anytime anywhere
blinkist has the best insights
from over 4 500 non-fiction books you
can read or listen to them
podcast style in the first 100 people to
go to blinkist.com
michael knowles are going to get
unlimited access for one week to try it
out
you'll also get 25 off if you want the
full membership the 7-day trial is
completely free
you can cancel at any time during that
period it's so easy just get the app
right you open it up and then you go
boom you got your books right there
great great one popped right up
is how to win friends and influence
people this is a book where you think
okay you can sit and you can read it and
it'll take you a week or however long to
read it or you can get
all the nuggets that you need from that
book it's classic of the genre
you can get it in 15 minutes 13 minutes
on blanket go
do it check it out seven day free trial
completely free
you can cancel at any time during that
period head on over to blinkist today
let's roll the tape
but it's not selling pringles
[Music]
is this the same kids do you think or
it's different different kids
[Music]
if you think you know what happens next
oh the whole thing is like oh is he
gonna steal is he gonna rob is he gonna
these are the black stories we've been
shown
a narrow view that limits our
understanding
[Music]
but there's so much more to see oh he's
not gonna rob the house he's gonna
he's gonna see his mom oh the woman's
not a single mother
she's got a husband or something
oh see you bigot you you oh
he's they're not stealing they're seeing
their friend or something
and pain see how dare you
a picture of black life it's the full
picture
i don't i have no truly no idea what
this is selling i couldn't even
venture a guess
[Music]
birthday less widen the screen
i'm gonna say procter gamble so we can
widen our view it's proctor and gamble
because whenever i don't know it's just
always proctor and gamble
man i learned that lesson the hard way
because
because whenever there's just some
ridiculous commercial out there
and they're not selling any product at
all i'm like
i don't know i don't know i don't know
but then i it's always proctor and
gamble for some reason you know this
this is really bad stuff though because
what
what they're saying is that people have
prejudices and of course they do people
always have prejudices that's
a prejudice right is just taking things
we know about the world and then making
snap judgments based on it it's not
it's not the same thing as being totally
close-minded or bigoted it's just saying
look when you don't when you have
imperfect information you've got to form
conclusions about things just to get
through our own lives right
so they're saying people have prejudices
and some of these prejudices are racial
and some of these prejudices are about
black people and so you saw
you saw that pregnant woman with the
kids and you assumed
she was a single mother but how you
bigot there's the husband
shows up in a nice car well yeah that's
good i i hope that happens but the fact
remains that 70
of black people in the united states are
born out of wedlock so you're not going
to fix that problem
by pretending that that's just a figment
of people's imagination it's not it's a
real problem
it's extraordinarily widespread it's
destroying the black community
it's horrific for the children it's
horrific for the women and it's bad for
the men too
because the men are just going to go off
and be derelicts and live
terrible lives if they don't take
responsibility for their kids and for
the ladies in their life
hopefully just one lady so it's just
it's it's under this
guise of compassion and actually how
dare you
you're the problem because you have a
perception based on statistics or
whatever
but that's no if as long as we just
pretend that
it's not a problem then the problem will
go wait well it's not going to go away
the problem's actually gotten
much much worse great job proctor and
gamble at least the one nice thing we
can say about this is at least
at least they're predictable at least
now you you can get it
you can send me in more vote commercials
i very much look forward to the next one
i don't know what my what is my average
i kind of messed up the uber one a
little bit did i get it did i not get it
i'm just i'm gonna take it i'm gonna say
that i got about 50 on that one we'll
see you next time
[Music]
you